Це перший рік, коли медики почали говорити в голос,
до цього медики ніколи не говорили про проблеми чи про потреби.
Бо кожен голосний звук з вуст медика одразу присікався.
Заслужені лікарі України запевняли, що коронавірус це масонський зговір
і такого вірусу немає, що це все брехня.
Страх тільки за близьких і друзів, а за себе ні.
- Як Ви вважаєте, чому нам не дозволили знімати відділені?
Бо відділення як не було готове так і зараз не готове.
Пройшло 9 місяців пандемії на жаль нічого не забезпечено, нічого не змінено і навіть пандемія цього не змінила.
Байдужість керівництва призвела до того, що люди наприклад перебувають без гарячої води.
У мене там волонтерський бойлер. Але він навіть не встановлений.
Він уже тиждень стоїть. Але він не встановлений для пацієнтів.
В таку морозяну погоду люди,  які мають мити часто руки навіть гарячою водою не забезпечені.
Тобто в палаті холодно вода?
Не те що в палаті. У нас один санвузол на 30 людей.
З одним унітазом і одним рукомийником і в ньому ж холодна вода,
у нас немає засобів для гігієни. Душових чи санвузлів у нас немає.
- Це йдеться саме про інфекційні відділення, де лежать хворі на "ковід"?
Так.
Я пройшла шлях від медсестри до лікаря і велику кількість років спостерігала за тим,
як пригнічують медиків. Найлегше управляти медиками.
Тому що медики пройшли великий шлях, щоб прийти на свою посаду
і кожне керівництво цим користується. Завжди.
Це перший рік коли медики почали говорити в голос,
до цього вони ніколи не говорили про проблеми чи про потреби.
Одночасно з моїми стрімами, з розривом в кілька годин,
скликались брифінги, була суперечлива інформацій тій, яку я подавала
і тоді почала робити стрім з відділення і показувати, як воно насправді є,
щоб  їхні слова і проти моїх фактів,  відео і фотофіксації.
І тоді це вже зовсім інше було.
Спочатку мене хотіли переконати в тому, що жоден медик у лікарні мене не підтримує за мої стріми.
Що, можливо, пацієнти чи люди, але не медики.
І це говорили кілька разів вдень поки я не почала ходити по відділеннях, в гості,
де звичайні санітарки, медсестри і лікарі висловлювали свою підтримку і подяку обіймами.
І тоді зрозуміла, що це метод боротьби зі мною...
У мене і не було страху перед хворобою. Це був професійний момент.
Бо інфекціоністів мало і коронавірус пов'язаний суто з інфекційними хворобами,
тому на когось скинути цей обов'язок не можливо.  І тому мусиш працювати.
А хто ж якщо не ми. І нас мало. Страх тільки за близьких і друзів, а за себе ні.
Що говорити, якщо у моєму відділені заслужені лікарі України, які мають такі звання,
отримані вже під час пандемії.
Але на початку вони запевняли, що коронавірус це масонський зговір
і що такого вірусу немає.
Були такі випадки, коли онук приходив до дідуся 86 років, він не хотів їсти
і розумів, що скоро помре. А онук мав позитивний тест на короновірус
і його навмисно привезли в лікарню, бо дідусь лиш з ним погоджувався їсти.
Такі речі дуже важкі,  бо у нас багато пацієнтів яким повинні допомагати родичі.
У нас не так багато медперсоналу,  щоб біля кожного поставити санітарку чи медсестру…
Є люди, які навіть корову продали, я журналістам це говорила на камеру, є ті які кредити брали.
Нещодавно подруга питала чи ліки, які їм виписали в лікарні,  безкоштовно дають чи ні,
бо пацієнти хочуть брати кредити. Багато таких випадків.
Це сумні речі, які медик немає на собі виносити, але все одно ми дотичні до цього і мусимо.
Звичайна українська родина. Щоправда, у мене жодного медика немає в родині,
я єдина, хто пішов в медицину. Правда не підтримували спочатку.
Я в училище вступала без батьків, таємничо це робила.
У мене сім'я філологів, тато журналіст і всі так думали, що з моїм характером
треба було бути юристом, журналістом, економістом, але точно не медиком.
Революція гідності затягнула, потім війна, вона взагалі затягнула дуже сильно,
бо всі свої відгули я їздила в АТО і останні два-три роки, коли менше потрібно волонтерська допомога
і більше як медика, руками, я дуже часто їздила туди і залишилась в госпіталях.
Навіть якби я не була інфекціоністом я б все одно допомагала
і була з коронавірусом, можливо, як медсестра чи як санітарка. Але я б не була осторонь цього.
Майже усі партії пропонували місце у списках, коли починали виборчу компанію.
І дуже багато людей писало і просили, щоб можна було більше зробити.
Тут виходить, що борюсь лише за інфекційне відділення і інфекційних пацієнтів, а люди просили,
щоб активність можна було перелаштувати на інші галузі.
І просили, щоб йшла до влади.  Це була двояка ситуація для мене.
У мене один з найвищих показників в області.
При тому, що я не робила виборчу кампанію, бо не було часу на це.
За ці останні тижні після оголошення результатів до мене і театри, і церкви
звертаються, і соціальні заклади, там де діти перебувають,  уже звертаються за допомогою.
- 2020 рік виявився складним для українців. Як би Ви його підсумували?
Він складний для всієї планети. Але треба шукати позитив.
Ми реально змінили цінності, ми розуміємо цінність часу, життя, родини.
І другий позитив це зміни для медицини.
Для медичних закладів, які були пригнічені, недоглядані.
Майже всі моменти. Діагностика... У нас з'явилося дуже багато діагностичних речей
у всіх закладах, у нас оновилась матеріальна база майже в усіх закладах України.
- Що українцям і світові очікувати від 2021 року?
Світ чекає на вакцину і на її ефективність. Це єдине на що ми так чекаємо від початку пандемії.
Ні на що так не чекали, як вакцини. Чекаємо припинення цих мутації вірусу…
Думаю, що основне - щоб не припинилась увага до медицини в Україні.